position and as a team they're more  fluid offensive nearly knocked away by  holiday  boy this is a very physical game as  irving throws it in goes down hard on  his  on his right shoulder he's shaking up  now he's holding his right leg it's five  on four  irving's still down connecting can't hit  the three rebounds ripping  and now they're bringing up and the  timeout is called as kyrie irving  holding that right shin  and banging the court  [Applause]  nets of course have had their share of  injuries all season long including their  stars  it looked like he came down on that  ankle landing on janice's foot yep  so we'll take a quick break and check on  kyrie irving when we come back